During the American civil war,
the country was embroiled in so much fighting that it's astounding,
that the country still exists today, though.
Fight was more profound than the struggle for black slaves to finally earn their
freedom. After all the staunch belief from the American South,
that they had a right to own slaves was a primary force in the war,
beginning in the first place,
but even decades before the war highlighted the need for America to end slavery,
many people were finding ways to get slaves to freedom.
Harriet Tubman went above and beyond, but that's just one part of how rich
Harriet Tubman was born in the month of March 18, 22 in Dorchester County,
Maryland. Her birth name was Arameans Ross,
and she was affectionately known as minty during our childhood.
She was also born into slavery as a parent's Harriet and Ben worked a plantation
near the Blackwater river in Dorchester. Obviously,
records are hard to come by and regarding Harriet's birth,
but historians have reached the year of 1822 as probable for a birth based
on documents. From the time though,
her gravestone still says 1820 and she herself says that it was 1825.
We also don't know a lot about our family other than the fact that our
grandmother arrived in America around a slave ship.
As a mother was a cook for Mary brought us who oversaw the plantation.
Her father looked over all the timber production. The couple had nine children,
including Harriet's, but found it harder and harder to keep the family together.
As slavery's massive reach encroached,
three of their daughters were sold off losing touch with the family forever.
But when they came to sell off,
one of their sons Harriet's mother boldly stood up and refused.
Mary brought S shockingly broadest relented, and the sale was canceled.
Harriet saw this defiance and she was inspired by it.
Harry is eventually he was given work as a nurse made when she was five or six,
while also helping to raise some of our siblings.
She also worked for a local planter named James Cook,
and she would often work his property checking muskrat traps throughout marshes
that dotted his land.
They worked so hard even when she got measles and had to be careful by her
already busy mother and nurse may task back at the plantation was much harder
than she could have anticipated regular with things would occur.
Even for simple things like a baby crying,
Harry already was developing clever ways to avoid the pain and the beatings like
wearing extra layers of clothing and just playing running away for days on.
[Inaudible].
It's time, Tubman was given more arduous tasks like plowing and holding logs.
She was easing into our teenage years.
And even though her home was one of the most horrible places,
you could imagine it was still all she had.
And she tried to find whatever small piece there that she could Tubman was
unable to read, but knew the Bible and its teachings quite well from my mother,
that religious strength was seemed to be tested as she suffered a nasty injury
on the plantation around the time of her adolescence.
As another slave was attempting to escape.
One of the plantation supervisors threw a metal weight at them,
which instead struck Harriet in the hat.
The injury was profound and not only led to her suffering seizures and
excruciating headaches,
but it led to a period of having what she said were visions.
She began to reject the ideas in the new Testament of the Bible,
and instead pursued tales of revolution and freedom.
Whether the injury caused this change in our mind is unknown,
but the symptoms remained with her to her dying day and recent historians think
she might've had a form of epilepsy after the attack.
Harriet reached a first roadblock to freedom early.
That was a practice back then called nanometer,
which is an agreement where an owner formerly frees a slave.
Oftentimes this came about when a slave reached an age where the owners felt
they had gotten all possible use out of them physically and mentally Harriet's
parents was supposed to be granted manometer at the age of 45,
but their owners all but ignored that when they took over.
So besides her parents being denied some small semblance of freedom,
Harriet too, would remain in slavery.
She did barrier free black man named John Tubman in 1844.
And that wasn't so strange around those parts of Maryland back then I really
enjoy straddled the line.
And so roughly half the black population in those regions were free.
That didn't matter to the law marches.
Harriet would still remain a slave regardless of a marriage status.
She did choose a tree name soon after no longer was she airman to Ross.
She was now Harriet Tubman. Uh, health was still an issue. However,
whether that was directly from the head injuries and subsequent symptoms is
unclear.
Her owners were beginning to consider her reliability and it's not having the
value that she wants. How does a worker in 1849,
they tried to sell Harriet off and found a tankers and remained humble escaping
from her real-world is into the piece of prayer,
even asking forgiveness for our owners,
that line of prep eventually changed to asking for the Lord to take him,
which actually happened a week later.
The death of Rona instantly put her life in immediate disarray.
Where would she end up? What would become a family?
The thought of spending another day as the property of someone else made Harriet
to sign the breaking free was the only option.
September.
Oh, the 17, 1849 Harriet's. And two of her brothers may bear great escape.
Their absence went unnoticed for two weeks,
which should have bought them a nice cushion of time.
But the news then got announced in the local paper and her two brothers became
fearful eventually returning to the plantation Harry that's of the faithful
family member joins them, but this was just the trial run various.
She was going to get out not long after Harriet busted out again this time
without her brothers in tow,
she wanted to make sure that her family knew she was planning this and sent them
coded messages through song.
She traveled by night with the stars as our guide and utilizing the underground
railroad, which was a loose network of activists and former slaves.
While little is known about which direction she took,
it's likely she followed the nearby Choptank river,
then went North through Delaware and Pennsylvania eventually ending up in
Philadelphia.
The underground railroad was a ticket to avoid capture rewards for fugitive
slaves were plentiful,
but so too were people who were eager to be on the right side of history.
The railroad, well,
not actually any kind of transit system was a series of houses and safe houses,
which extended as far North, as Canada.
And as far South as Mexico it's origins go back to the late 17 hundreds.
And by the time the civil war began,
it's estimated that over a hundred thousand slaves found their freedom through
the underground railroad. The North star,
which Harriet followed to Philadelphia,
became a kind of crucial mapping points leading the way North to the free
States.
There was even a spiritual song at the time called follow the drinking gourd,
which was referencing the big dip of constellation and code,
and basically giving directions for slaves to find their freedom. Hurry.
It used these same clues and markets to find a way,
but a journey wasn't without peril.
She had to hide by day and then use the cover of night to find the next friendly
location. Some people at our stops how to pretend to work for the family.
So as not to blow her cover, when she finally crossed into Pennsylvania,
after in 90 miles, several week track on foot, she said,
when I found that I had crossed that line,
I looked at my hands to see if I was the same person.
There was such a glory over everything,
but someone came like a gold through the trees and over the fields.
And I felt like I was in heaven.
It was free for now,
but a family wasn't neither was the over 3 million other slaves in the United
States,
Congress in 1850 tightens penalties on aiding slaves and escaping and forced
authorities to help capture them, even if it was in a free state,
even in the relative safety of Philadelphia, where Harry,
it was poor Irish immigrants and blacks were embroiled in racial tensions of
jobs and work.
Harriet was able to find some odd jobs here and there and save a little bit of
money while she thought up ways to get our people. That own tastes of freedom.
She didn't have to wait long in December,
1850 word reached her that her niece Casar and two children were about to be put
up for sale back in Cambridge, Maryland Tubman,
headed to Baltimore and blade low with a family member until the sale date,
John BOLI was Cassano's husband, and it was a free black man.
He was able to put up with a winning bid fab. When the man running the auction,
went off to have lunch, belly snuck, OSI,
and the children to a safe house until nightfall.
He then loaded them all onto a canoe and sailed 60 miles up to Baltimore where
Harriet was waiting to take them to Philadelphia.
This was her first successful rescue,
but it was far from my lost in spring 1851.
She had it to Maryland again to rescue her brother Moses.
She was becoming more confident in our travels and word was beginning to spread
around the region and to a family of our exploits and the fall of that year.
She actually returned to the home County of Dorchester this time to attempt to
rescue her husband's John Tubman, unbeknownst to her John had remarried still.
She tried to persuade him to follow how to save for pots.
John was adamant that he was happy with his new life and his new wife.
And though Harriet was upset. She designed it. It was best to leave him behind.
She instead found some slaves in the neighboring area who did want to escape and
took them back to Philadelphia. With that in December, she escorted 11 more.
Those 11 slaves,
she rescued are a special note because it's very likely she led them to freedom
after they were under the care of Frederick Douglas.
He stated in his autobiography that he was looking after 11 slaves at his home.
And the timing of her leading that number of fugitives seems to match up
perfectly Douglas and Tubman already had a great respect for each other,
or is he was a former slave before becoming the prominent abolitionist.
You know, today he eventually wrote a very poignant letter in her honor,
remarking,
how he very publicly denounced slavery while she fought it privately Harriet
Tubman led 13 Voyagers back to Maryland in all rescuing some 70 slaves and
leading them North to safety. She saved even more of her family, her brothers,
their wives and children.
She counseled with many other slaves directing them before they embarked on
their own perilous trips to freedom. She mostly worked during the winter.
As those climates seem to offer the least chances being course,
she ends up passengers usually took off on a Saturday nights as runaway notices.
Wouldn't be put into newspapers until Monday morning, Aria devised,
all sorts of tricks and tactics to avoid detection.
Sometimes she would carry angry chickens.
So she wouldn't have to make eye contact with plantation owners,
even though she was illiterate,
she would Fain reading newspapers so passes by wouldn't catch on to her mission.
She also carried a gun with her.
This wasn't just for protection against people who would love to have caught her
and gotten their award.
It was also to make sure no one she was rescuing would have second thoughts
about being rescued after all,
if someone had tried to back out that would have put the safety of the whole
group in jeopardy, it was known around those regions of Maryland,
that someone was helping a good number of slaves escape,
but they never got wise to it being Tubman.
They figured she had escapes and gotten to a better place and have no reason to
return many thoughts. White abolitionists were behind all the escapes,
but for all of her daring expeditions into the belly of the beast,
including where she herself had toiled in slavery, she was never once caught.
One of her very last trips was to steal into Maryland and rescue her parents in
1855.
Her father had purchased the rights to our mother and both lived as free blacks,
but the area still wasn't the kindest place for them to reside in 1857,
the father got in trouble for being found, protecting eight slaves in his home.
Harriet saw the danger he was facing and headed down to Maryland for one last
mission. She picked her parents up,
led them all the way to Ontario Canada and got them situated on a piece of labs
that also included her brothers and many other former slaves.
Harry found a way to reunite much of a family after being separated by so many
forces for so long.
Yeah.
Harriet Tubman cross paths with another famous anti-slavery force in 1858,
when she was introduced to John Brown and abolitionists to advocated for armed
revolt against slavery.
You may remember his name being attached to the famous raid on Harper's ferry in
1859.
He and his group seized a federal armory with the intention of arming slaves
while the raid was first successful.
It didn't last long and Brown and his men were captured.
John Brown was actually the first person convicted of treason in us history.
And he was hanged Brown and Tubman were fast friends,
even if Tubman didn't believe in his more violent methods.
Brown endearingly called our general Tubman.
And he used her vast knowledge of the underground railroad and similar networks
plan his own maneuvers. They also had Tubman reach out for the former slaves.
She had helped relocate to Canada to request their help and fighting for his
cause on may the eighth,
1858 Brown met with Tubman's people and proceeded to unveil his plan for the
Harper's ferry rate.
His plans were almost immediately put on hold when the government got wind of
them, but he still worked on them behind the scenes.
Often with Harriet Tubman's help.
But when it came time for the raid to take place,
Tuttleman was unavailable for Brown to lean on for guidance.
He forged ahead anyway, and while it was an eventual failure,
he had already won the praise of top men and many other leaders of the
anti-slavery cause Harriet herself said he'd done more in dying than a hundred
men would in living in 1859.
Harry joins with another abolitionists this time,
Republican Senator William seaward,
and she was able to purchase a plot of land in New York state.
It costs a $1,200 and it's the town where it was located was perfect for Harriet
is enabled to get family members away from these sometimes brutal Canadian
climates. And the nearby city of Orban was very anti-slavery.
Harriet still went down South from time to time to conduct rescue missions.
And oftentimes you would bring them right to our New York property creating a
safe Haven of sorts for all kinds of farmers,
1861. So all the civil war breakouts, it was inevitable.
The push and pull inside the country regarding slavery and its moral
implications was bound to explode at one point or another.
And when it boiled over,
Harry believed in the cause of the union and its anti-slavery stance.
She wanted to help.
And so she joined a group of abolitionists from Boston and Philadelphia,
as they headed down to South Carolina where the civil war began,
she assisted in the camps that helping to Kapha escaped and recently freed
slaves.
She even began assembling a regimen of soldiers consisting of former slaves
under the tutelage of general, David Hunter,
one person who wasn't pleased with the work Harriet and general Hunter were
doing was president Abraham Lincoln.
He didn't think it was time yet to force the Southern States to free the slaves.
And he actually came down pretty hard on them for their actions talking of
course wasn't onesy mint,
so words and she retorted back against Lincoln for what she saw as weakness.
God, won't let master Lincoln beat the South to lead does the right thing.
Master Lincoln. He's a great man and I am a poor Negro,
but the Negro can tell master Lincoln how to save the money. And the young men,
you can do it by setting the Negro free.
That's what master Lincoln ought to know.
It's still something that helps where she could. She worked out of port Royal,
South Carolina,
mostly helping scores of soldiers suffering from smallpox and dissymmetry she
made her own pies and root beer to earn some money denying the rations that the
government attempted to give her for a work.
It took two years until Lincoln's emancipation proclamation was issued.
The first step in ending slavery,
Harriet was still working out of South Carolina and the landscape was much like
where she grew up in Maryland.
So she led bands of Scouts around the swamps and rivers in the area,
gaining reconnaissance and Intel on the enemy Confederate forces.
She works under the direct supervision of the secretary of war.
Edward stands in and then later rated James Montgomery with information that
helped him take the city of Jacksonville.
Florida area was often pulling strings behind the battlefields,
but that didn't mean she didn't take parts in some of the action as well.
Tubman became the first woman to lead a battlefield operation.
When general Montgomery designed it to sack a series of plantations along the
South Carolina river Tubman advised him and helped to lead the rate.
She guided boats of soldiers around enemy mines in the waters she watched as
union men stormed the shore in burned down Lamentations,
the slaves in zones that realized this was a liberation and Flint awards that
waiting boats on the shore,
carrying what food and possessions they could as the plantation owners trying to
start.
The mass Exodus Harry at beams with pride at watching helps happen there that
day. Over 750 slaves were free. During these missions,
Harriet was rightly ordered as a hero and many of the people she helped escape
that captors went on to join the union army,
to fight Harriet Tubman out the union for two more years,
caring for wounded soldiers, scouting, enemy territory,
and helping freed slaves adjust to their new lives.
She did all of this while also traveling back to New York to see our family and
those living at our sanctuary. Once the war ended in 1965,
she went back there for good.
[Inaudible].
Harriet spends her older years caring for her family and parents and taking in
boarders to help analysts with money. One of them was a man named Nelson,
Charles Davis. She quickly took two though. It was 22 years. Her junior,
they married in 1869 and adopted a little baby girl named Gurty five years
later. Tubman's old abolition comrades never forgot her.
Even as the years rolled on one,
even Pender biography for which Harriet source and royalties from she didn't
even receive the recognition. She deserved from a past deeds,
which was proven time and time again,
a bill that was proposed in Congress to pay her for her service with the union
army was defeated in 1874.
She was swindled out of money by conmen and assaulted during a train ride,
even though she had government papers proving,
she could sit in the section she was in, she still fought.
She traveled up and down the East coast in the 1890s to fight for women's rights
to vote. She also turns more to water spiritual side. In 1983,
she donated a sizeable piece of land as to the African Methodist Episcopal Zion
church.
With the stipulation that it would be a home for aged and indignant colored
people, frustrations mounted, as it took years to complete the facility.
And once he did open, it challenged a hundred dollars as an entrance fee. Still.
She was happy to put her name on the Harriet Tubman home for the aged.
It would be one of her last cherish memories, the seizures, and had problems.
She dealt with her entire life with more numerous.
She underwent brain surgery in Boston, somewhere around this time,
having a skull opened up with no anesthesia biting down on a bullet slunk.
She'd seen mortally wounded soldiers during the past, tough to the ends in 1913,
she passed away from pneumonia and her namesake home for the elderly.
Her last words were I go to prepare a place for you.
She was buried with some military honors in the town of Auburn, New York,
where she had created a Haven for those who wants enslaved after guiding so many
on the underground railroad to freedom. And I really hope you found that video.
Interesting. If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe.
Thank you for watching.